[Musique]
des centaines de milliers de
britanniques sont descendus dans les
rues de londres pour lancer un message
clair à la première ministre théorie ça
mais ils ne veulent plus du bric site et
exigent la tenue d'un deuxième
référendum pour empêcher le pays de
sortir de l'union européenne en scandant
laisser le peuple décider et en
brandissant des pancartes réclamant une
constitution populaire
il espère changer l'issue du premier
référendum tenu il ya près de trois ans
en juin 2016 je crois que nous n'avons
pas pris une décision en ayant toutes
les informations dont nous avions besoin
nous ne savions pas ce que serait le
break 6 explique sept manifestants c'est
important parce que le pays dans le
chaos
cet homme nous avons des dirigeants
incompétents
ça n'aurait jamais dû arriver ce nouvel
épisode dans cette saga du break site
mais encore plus de pression sur la
première ministre térisse a mis une
crise politique qui risque d'emporter
son gouvernement jeudi les dirigeants
européens ont encore repoussé l'échéance
du break site initialement prévu le 29
mars
devant l'impasse ils ont repoussé la
date ultime au 12 avril théorie ça me
refuse de tenir un second référendum et
espère toujours pouvoir faire entériner
son accord par les députés britanniques
la semaine prochaine après deux échecs
depuis janvier
pendant ce temps la grogne populaire
atteint des sommets une pétition en
ligne demandant parlement de renoncer
aux briques site a obtenu plus de deux
millions de signatures ici marie claude
dupont radio canada montréal